[Music]
[Music]
with the upcoming release of breath the
wild sequel the legend of zelda series
is soon to be
20 games strong not counting spin-off
games remakes and
these specimens in order to keep a
series with this many games still going
strong to this day
nintendo had to innovate experiment and
change up the gameplay for each
iteration
as a result each game has their own
unique traits and mechanics which rarely
transition from one game to the next
some of these mechanics are solely
missed and while the desire for change
from the side of nintendo is completely
understandable
it would be nice if we could see some of
these traits return in future games
so for this video let's pretend for a
moment that we live in a perfect world
in which breathtak 2 will take
inspiration from every previous
installment
all the while still presenting us with
new stuff we didn't know we wanted as
nintendo has done so many
times in the past in that case which
aspect from each game could the zelda
team use to make brethwald's sequel the
perfect game
today i'm joined by xenogamer and
together we explore this question game
by game and in order of release date
and we each give our own take on a
specific one this video will cover the
first half of the total list so after
you're done watching this one be sure to
head over to zeno's channel and check
out part 2.
this one might seem a bit unnecessary
since breath the wild was already
largely based on the philosophy of the
first game
despite these inspirations however there
are still things about the original
which the sequel could take notes from
in particular the way it handled its
exploration and sense of discovery
despite adapting the non-linear style of
its nes elder the discoveries you made
in breath the wild were not in the same
vein as the original
the dungeons or should i say the divine
beasts were able to be tackled out of
order but they didn't need to be
discovered
since well they can literally be seen
stomping around or flying around from
afar
and secondly impa tells you exactly
where to find them
in its nes counterpart things were not
always as straightforward which made the
discovery of a dungeon
better sword secret shop or any other
mysteries all the more satisfying
now i am by no means saying that we need
to go back to bombing every wall and
burning every bush but the discoveries
you made in breath the wild definitely
lacked a certain variety
no matter what kind of secret area or
riddle you stumbled across
you knew that in the end the result was
going to be either a shrine or a korok
seed which in and of itself
kinda diminishes the surprise factor
secret caves were practically
non-existent in breath the wild
whenever you did find a bombable wall
don't expect anything more than just a
small little alcove with a treasure
chest or a korok seed
imagine climbing a hard-to-reach
mountain range and finding a small
little crevice and literally stumble
upon a full-fledged secret dungeon or
mini dungeon with its own unique style
and atmosphere that's the kind of stuff
the original definitely had going for it
[Music]
zelda 2 is a very different game by
zelda standards and
that's something i really personally
admire about it there's a reason this
game is called the black sheep of the
franchise
the game is more of an rpg than it is an
adventure game
battles take place outside of the
overworld map and you level up and gain
experience as you play
there are many unique things i could say
breath of the wild too should learn from
zelda 2
but above all i just wanted to embrace
one thing
be weird zelda 2 wasn't afraid to be
different
rpg and platforming elements a plethora
of new enemies
no ganon and even a freaking npc named
error
in my eyes zelda is at its best when it
embraces its less traditional side
goes off the rails a bit isn't afraid to
surprise players
breath of the wild has been endlessly
compared to the original legend of zelda
some might even go as far to say it's
basically a modern day remake
and i think that zelda 2 might have the
same kind of influence on breath of the
wild too
don't be afraid to stray from that line
in story or gameplay
dare to be different
a link to the past is the game which
first introduced the concept of shifting
between two different dimensions
in a sense doubling the size of the
overworld which in case of breath the
wall 2 couldn't be more fitting
anuma and his team have already
confirmed that the sequel will see us
revisiting the same hyrule scene in the
previous game
this has become somewhat of a cause for
concern amongst fans since in the three
and a half years since its release this
map has been turned inside out with
every nook and cranny visited and
discovered
so much so that some of us have resorted
to looking beyond the borders of what we
are allowed to see in the game
the light world dark world mechanics
seen in a link to the past was a great
way to turn an otherwise
quite simplistic overworld into
something much deeper
as opposed to twilight princess where
the other dimension was identical
just darker and more gloomy in a link to
the past the differences were pretty
significant
caves which were present in one were
absent in the other bridges broken or
intact and even entire areas were
completely different
such as the desert turning into a swamp
in the other world
something similar to this would make the
overworld in the sequel feel brand new
without actually adding new provinces
it remains to be seen if something like
this is doable since the map
is a lot bigger than the one in a link
to the past but maybe instead it could
be restricted to only certain areas
i played through link's awakening for
the first time last year with the
release of its switch remake
and i loved the game but was surprised
by what stood out to me the most as i
played through it
a mystery a mystery i already knew the
answer to
i played this game 27 years after its
initial release
so i had been spoiled on the events of
the story long before i booted up the
game
and from the very beginning i knew the
true nature of coho li island
but that still stuck with me as the most
essential part
to what makes this game so good the
mystery
and on top of that the overall
atmosphere
link's awakening tells a very simple
story but it's how that story unfolds
and affects you
that makes it so magical the way it
changes how you look at the world around
you
it takes everything you've grown to care
about and tells you if you beat the game
you're pulling the trigger on all that
and that's what breath of the wild 2
could learn from link's awakening the
way it uses atmosphere to drive the
game's storytelling
as well as how it pulls off an excellent
mystery
leading to a tremendous plot twist
the first thing that would come to mind
regarding ocarina of time would of
course be that which is represented by
its title
time travel however we have already
covered shifting between two dimensions
in a link to the past which is very
similar in a lot of ways and
having both traveling between dimensions
and time travel would perhaps be a
little bit too much
besides ocarina of time isn't the only
game to feature time travel
instead i would opt for breath the wild
to take inspiration from ocarina of
time's turning point
a lot of 3d zelda games have some sort
of a turning point in the story but none
are as prevalent as the one in ocarina
of time
the contrast between the child section
and the adult section was
immense and was a real game changer for
the story all of a sudden you transition
from a fragile kid who is cast into a
dangerous destiny into a full-fledged
badass hero
not only that but so many other things
start snowballing as soon as you reach
this point
ganondorf stole the triforce zelda is
forced to flee and the world has been
destroyed or taken over in your absence
breath of the wild lacked such a turning
point
technically it did have one but it took
place before the events of the actual
game and can only be viewed through
memories
the sequel has a chance to rectify this
mistake and have us experience moments
like these through
actual gameplay say for instance the
first few dungeons take place before
ganondorf wakes up
and after he does the world changes
radically and we are presented with new
challenges and objectives
[Music]
there are many reasons i call majora's
mask one of my favorite zelda games
but one of the biggest reasons is
because in many cases
it made me care about the side quests
more than i cared about the main story
there is an elegance to the side quests
in majora's mask
unlike any other game in the series
every quest happens simultaneously over
a period of three days
and as a result of this and the main
driving mechanic of time travel
throughout the game
all of the work you've done to improve
these people's lives is lost to time in
the end
it's a very dark and surreal experience
that i feel would be near impossible to
replicate again
but even if breath of the wild 2 can't
exactly carry over all of the concepts
that made majora's mask so special
i still think it has plenty to learn
from this game
you don't just remember majora's side
quest because of the unique
circumstances of the overarching system
of time in the game
you remember them because of the
characterization they showed ask most
zelda fans and i bet they will tell you
to this day
majora's mask is the most alive a world
has felt in the zelda series
almost every character is memorable with
their own motivations and daily schedule
they realistically react to the world
around them in the doom they are faced
with
not only that but their side quests have
a place in the world
in breath of the wild side quests are
often relegated to generic tasks given
from faceless npc
travelers these people are never really
given characteristics
they exist to give you a quest to reward
you with a reward that's not even worth
your time
and then disappear from your memory
forever and that's where breath of the
wild 2
needs to learn from the example of
majora unique characters in personality
and quest designed to fit into the world
that are fun to complete
and offer rewards that are actually
worth your time
despite being great games on their own
orkolf ages and seasons didn't introduce
too many new things aegis had time
travel and season sees you shifting
between different seasons which
influences the overworld both of which
we've seen in the past in some shape or
form
but things change when we look at the
games not as individual entities but as
a pair
by far the most unique aspect about them
was the ability to link the two
this allowed you to transfer certain
items from one to another
have characters traveling between two
worlds and getting the true ending to
each story requires combining the two
zelda games usually don't do alternative
or true endings
but guess which one does breath of the
wild and not only is it one of the few
games to have a true ending it's also
the first time we've seen a direct
sequel which takes place
almost right after and stars the same
link in zelda how cool would it be if
breathtwide 1 and 2 would somehow be
linked through save files
and it makes sense if you think about it
since if a player hasn't completed
certain quests in the original
they wouldn't know about it and thus it
would be strange if it pops up in the
sequel seemingly out of nowhere
as an example if you've never collected
the master sword in the original you
might start without it in the sequel and
you have to go get it first
or if you've never completed the
terrytown side quest the settlement
might not exist in breath the while too
not to mention all the amazing armor
sets and other collectibles we obtained
in breath of the wild which would be
nice if at least some of them would
transfer over to the new game
like the tunic of the wild for instance
[Music]
four swords might not be the most
beloved zelda game but it does exhibit
something i always loved seeing in the
zelda
series which is new villains four swords
was the first game to introduce us to
vati
the dark power hungry sorcerer as great
of a villain as ganondorf can be
there is yet to be an instance where i
have not enjoyed seeing a new character
step into the role as antagonist
whether it be secondary or main not only
is it nice to see a new villain we can
face off against every once in a while
but as commonplace as it's become to see
ganon or ganondorf playing the role of
series villain
seeing new villains in the series is
something i've come to see is quite
refreshing
i'd love to see a totally new or even
returning side villain in breath of the
wild too
to mix up the formula just as four
swords did
in many ways
this one is quite on the nose but yeah
sea exploration
it's safe to say that exploring the open
waters in breath of the wild
sucked and this is without taking the
ability to dive on the water into
account
the raft was slow and tedious and it
would be nice if we have something
better like a sailboat to traverse the
big blue and aside from an easier way to
get around the seas
what good would sea exploration be if
there's nothing to explore
expanding the sea borders a bit more and
having more accessible islands would
obviously have to come with it
in terms of side quests even tide island
was definitely a fan favorite so it
would make sense to add some more
islands with cool stuff on them
perhaps even with new races enemies
wildlife and maybe even a dungeon hiding
on one of them
and that concludes part 1 of this list
if you like this video be sure to head
over to xenogamer's channel and check
out part 2
where we go over the rest of the games
in the series a big thanks to zeno for
joining me in this video
and as always a massive thanks to my
patreon supporters who make these videos
possible
one of which has just decided to become
a member a big thanks to lucas should
play zelda for joining
and indeed lucas you should play zelda
what are you waiting for
next week you will once again be treated
to a collaboration
this time with none other than our
favorite scottish zelda channel
hyrulegamer i hope to see you then this
is dawn
signing off and have a good one